everyone has been waiting for at the
stark children to be reunited me
included and the chance to bring them
together was very exciting the list of
people I'm going to kill probably the
scene I was looking forward to the most
was the scene between sons and Aria in
the Crypt when they're standing in front
of the statue for their father their
father pretty sad but just so powerful
doesn't look like him I've been carved
by someone who knew his face as I read
the progression of the season I realized
it wasn't gonna be all fun and games on
staff but to have Sophie around on set
again it's just been the best we were
really excited like when we first got
the scripts we were texting each other
did you read all the scripts here and
I'm like not yet and then I've read that
we reunited and then I rang her up oh my
god I just cried like finally yes
that's tricky complicated it's been so
much fun
she's my best mate and everyone's like
oh it's so nice she girls are back
together again and I was like just you
wait
because by week two you're all gonna
hate us because we're very annoying when
we're together before we left okay can I
cancel
you